the hateful eight is written and
directed by Quentin Tarantino and stars
the likes of samuel l.jackson Kurt
Russell Jennifer Jason Leigh as well as
Tim Ross just to name a few it's a story
of eight strangers who show up at a
lodge on a mountainside during a really
heavy Blizzard now some of them know
each other purely by reputation but all
of them are suspicious of one another
and the movie kind of turns into a
rated-r version of Clue you've ever clue
that awesome board game in a very fun
movie this movie kind of reminded me of
that you're in an isolated location
something goes wrong and no one knows
who the culprit is and you have to
decide as a viewer it's sort of a
whodunit but it's more of a mystery and
it's also a comedy and it's also a drama
and it's also a Western similar to all
of Quentin Tarantino's films it's
difficult to lock down a genre and
that's what makes hatefully so great
amongst a bevy of other things the guy's
done it again Quentin Tarantino you're a
master he's delivered yet another film
with icy-cold dialogue amazing sequences
that are entirely driven from just
people talking back and forth and the
movie is three hours long so that is
saying something now that does include
an overture as well as an intermission
this film is so old-fashioned it also
has an original score by Ennio Morricone
who you may know from everything he's
one of the best composers who ever lived
he's very famous for his good the bad
the ugly themes and his spaghetti
western movies and I think it's one of
the best scores she's ever composed now
one of the things I loved about the
score is that Quinn Tarantino is famous
for using music that's already existed
in movies now there's a song on John
Carpenter's The Thing
soundtrack also composed by Ennio
Morricone that song title was called
bestiality now that song for whatever
reason is not in the thing despite being
the best song on the entire album it was
omitted from the film for some reason
and I've always loved it ever since I
was young and I found the soundtrack and
for years I've actually listened to that
song and thought how cool would that
have been
if Carpenter had used that song in his
movie Quentin Tarantino found that song
and stuck it in hateful 8 at 2 amazing
sequences and it was so cool to finally
hear that song in a movie which is funny
because it is composed by any
Morricone you also composed the original
music for this movie but it was actually
composed for the thing that's just my
movie nerd brain and I was happy to hear
that song in the movie for once what's
also so great about this film is its use
of location you're isolated this is a
claustrophobic movie it's all in one
place and you feel like you're in this
cabin you feel like you're in this lodge
and it felt like the entire theater was
getting cold and every time someone
drank coffee or lit the fire I was like
oh thank goodness because you just feel
the location it was so well utilized
Kurt Russell was fabulous in this movie
he was funny he was likable he was a
total badass and I dug his character so
much but you know who my favorite
character in this entire film was that
of samuel l.jackson I loved him in this
movie I truly think that he is
oscar-worthy he hit all of the notes so
well every scene in which he had a
monologue especially one scene that I
will not spoil where he talks about
something had happened in the past oh my
gosh it was so amazing he was perfect in
this movie it's the best work I think
I've seen from him since maybe pulp
fiction and I mean that he was great
also excellent is Demian Bichir I
believe I said his name right I may be
incorrect but he was so good Bruce Dern
was great in the film everyone really
was great Walter Goggins I believe
that's his name
this cast Tim Roth oh my gosh Tim Roth
so great to see him back in a Tarantino
film everyone in this movie was on their
a-game it's amazing that I can just
watch a movie that has like a 10 minute
dialogue scene with just a few cuts back
and forth and I'm riveted because it's
so snappy it's so well-written and I'm
so glad that Tarantino decided to make
this movie despite the fact that the
script leaked back in the day I'm really
glad he went forth with it because this
is one of my favorite Tarantino films
there is action and yes there's gore as
you would expect in a Tarantino film the
sequences that I remember the most are
these amazing stare downs between
characters when they're just lay
everything on the line and saying it how
it is and Tarantino is a master of that
type of dialogue where someone just sits
down gives you an analogy and it's just
amazing to watch and it was so
old-fashioned to the super widescreen
the Eno Morricone scored the look
everything about this movie the overture
the intermission just screamed the 1960s
I
of the hateful eight I have but one flaw
with it and that is that like most
Tarantino films the story is nonlinear
at one point we go into the past at a
point to see how something started it's
not handled as swiftly as some of
Tarantino's other films it's a little
uneven in that branching arc at least
for me besides that man I love the
hateful eight I can't wait to see it
again I loved seeing some of these
actors on the screen delivering great
performances with fantastic dialog
Tarantino you still got it man don't
stop making films just keep doing it I'm
gonna give the hateful eight and a guy's
definitely check this film out I
strongly strongly recommend that it is
one of the best films of the year else
will let you guys know about my
promotion still going on with
crunchyroll.com if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris stuckman you
can get 30 days of that anime streaming
service for free I've been doing this
promotion all year these guys have been
amazing I love that website tons of
anime premium with no ads in HD and once
again that is crunchyroll.com slash
Chris stuckman 30 days for free that's
my gift to you on me enjoy see if you
like it thank you so much as always for
watching you're the best and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes